we're in a practice room at the
University of Nottingham and we're going
to talk about two of my most favorite
things in the whole universe which are
music and physics and how they come
together this is a wonderful paper a
really elegant and really sophisticated
analysis of a particular drumbeat what
they describe as a virtuoso drumbeat by
somebody called Jeff Porcaro some of you
who are drummers might be familiar with
that name those of you who aren't you
will have heard Jeff Porcaro
and this particular song that disk of
paper is based on is a relatively famous
song and you've probably heard it before
good so unfortunate Jeff Porcaro is no
longer with us he's gone to the grid big
gig in the sky and we have instead mr.
Sean Riley who many of you will know
from computer file who's going to help
out and do some of the drawing patterns
for us so we're going to ask you want to
do this beat it's actually a pretty
complicated and pretty difficult piece
of music to play a bit difficult rhythm
from a song called I keep forgetting by
somebody called Michael McDonald and
procore was a session musician he played
on lots of different records but this is
one of his most acclaimed pieces
although it sounds like a relatively
straightforward beat it's really
difficult to play in procore when he's
playing when you listen to the recorded
version it's got a fantastic groove it
makes you want to dance what the
researchers were interested in well
they've been they've been looking at
patterns and rhythms over the you know
course of a number of years now what
they wanted to focus on were variations
in the timing so that particular piece
of music that particular drumming
pattern has got a lot of water called
sixteenth notes so that and what they're
interested is that variation instead of
that those types of fluctuations in the
sound that's what they're interested in
and they have looked at that
mathematically they've looked at the
physics of that they've recorded picaros
drumbeat what most drummers would do
would they play a two hands
Picaro place at one hand and he
deliberately does that and they've even
got a quote from Carol it's absolutely
wonderful to have a draw more quoted in
in a physics paper and the quote from
because Carol is here I like the single
handed method because it's a lot
smoother feel for instance in the
Michael McDonald record I keep
forgetting I tried doing the alternating
stroke method so that method with both
hands and it sounded just to stiffen
staccato for me now most drummers would
say perhaps the opposite and it's just
because Parker was such a wonderful
drummer he can get all those dynamics
and all those situations and all that
groove in in terms of how each varies
the timing and also having varies the
volume the physics of fluctuations is
such a huge important and exciting area
because it connects to so many processes
in the universe around us generally when
we think of our heartbeat we think of
something which is really regular you
know the heartbeat is we think we've got
this really regular impulse happening
but in fact if we look at it and this is
from a wonderful book I recommend this
book a book called ubiquity by Marc
Buchanan where he discusses lots and
lots of aspects of fluctuations but this
is some theater where you look at how
the fluctuation of our heart rate
changes this is over the course as you
can see in terms of seconds on on the
axis here if we look it over over a long
time scale from as you can see from
54,000 up to 72,000 you can see it's far
from as far from even it's far from
perfectly time it's not like a metronome
it's what
but even if we go and look at if we zoom
in and a bit of this and looking a
shorter time scale what you see is the
same overall type of structure we call
this cell similar in that you know okay
you've got an average rate but you've
got fluctuations about that red and then
if we zoom in again it's the same type
of thing you've got an average rate but
you've got fluctuations about that red
so this this type of self-similarity is
also related to something called
fractals which you might have heard
about crops up right across nature on
very many different scales and that's
the important thing
it's scale free so for example with
earthquakes you get the same type of the
same type of idea happening in terms of
if you look at the magnitude of an
earthquake versus the frequency of
occurrence of those earthquakes so
fluctuations of high heart timing and
dynamics in a virtuoso drum track of a
popular music recording and the virtuoso
drum track is this Pro Carrol truck and
they've done they've gone to tyranny and
so they've digitized it and they've
looked at the the hi hat pattern in
particular and they've looked at the
onset of that and they've timed that and
they've looked at the variations in
timing and what they find is that they
get the same type of fluctuations or
some type of dynamics what they're
really interested in like so many other
physicists and scientists in general is
that the sort of science of fluctuations
the science of noise and they are
particularly keen to look at those
fluctuations in timing are they random
what fluctuations of what show
fluctuations off thereof in terms of how
he's hitting the drum the the the amount
of force he's putting into this long
stroke and also the timing just in terms
of when he hits the drum when it went
that the where the beat sort of fallen
where what beats he chooses to accent ie
to really accentuate and to bring out
and different drummers will do that very
very differently and what this paper was
it what the group was interested in
doing was looking at those fluctuations
to see is he just doing that randomly or
to what extent are they correlated to
what extent or what he's done previously
affecting what comes in the future is
the suggestion here that a magnificent
drummer like Picaro will have less
fluctuations that are bare drummer or
more fluctuations so it's very
interesting so those are very it's like
Goldilocks those is just right in terms
of you don't want to too random because
then it's all over the place on the year
gets very confused and you don't want it
too regular because in fact if you were
to regular it sounds just like a drill
machine you can program at your machine
or computer to be right on the bait just
exactly on the beat all the time and
that sounds awful to the human ear is
the suggestion that a magnificent
drummer like Picaro is doing this
deliberately or are they thinking he's
doing it subconsciously I the argument
would seem to be that he's doing it
subconsciously to the extent of course
was some deliberate aspect of it in
terms of he wants to add that groove but
he spent years playing the drums it's
not like he thinks before he's going to
lay down the track we're going on beat
three 278 I'm gonna be a little bit
louder than all the other beats or ever
it's it's natural and it's just like in
terms of guitarists they will choose to
accent certain notes but what's
remarkable is that this type of effect
they claim is is universal that when you
go from different drummers although they
will accent those beats and the timing
will very differently from drama to
drama if you look at the large picture
it's the same mathematics that describes
it every time and that's just remarkable
so in the conclusion to this paper you
can get this paper yourself it's online
it's open access it's a journal called
Clause 1 so it's entirely open access
you don't have to pay anything you know
that the paid the hundred dollars or
whatever to download it like so many
other papers so you can turn to the
conclusions and there's some really neat
conclusions in here to learn more about
the growth of iconic musicians such as
Jeff Porcaro
and about the universality of the
considered phenomena it would be
important to compare one different
recordings of the Sims Romo of course to
different drummers three various temples
or and rhythms for different musical
genres on five different playing styles
so single-handed sixteenth notes or
double-handed sixteen notes for example
so this is just a day themselves say
they're just scratching the surface and
it's the day of potential there for a
wide range of different studies is a no
huge amount of really interesting
research is vast
much as I like Picaro as a drama I must
admit that Michael McDonald song doesn't
quite do it for me right so what do we
want from you well if you think you can
do a better job than Sean or indeed if
you think you can do a better job than
Neal period or even if you don't think
you can do a better job but you're a
drummer and you'd like to help out
science and indeed you'd like to get
your name in a paper then what we want
you to do is to send in example samples
of you drumming the start of Tom Sawyer
or indeed the whole thing that's up to
you